so once again we have a claim that there
are Republican senators willing ready or
interested in convicting Donald Trump in
the expected impeachment trial in the
United States Senate now we had a story
a week or two ago that had a Democratic
Senator Chris Murphy saying that there
are Republican senators he says he can
count them on one hand but that there
are Republican senators who are ready to
convict Donald Trump in the Senate there
was really no evidence of this it was
just Chris Murphy saying that that's
what he believes we have another person
saying this but this time it is a
Republican not a Democrat it's bill weld
former Republican governor of
Massachusetts who is also running I
guess in some technical sense although
it's not going anywhere a primary
campaign against Donald Trump bill weld
was interviewed by the hill and he said
quote I know most of the senior
Republicans in the Senate they're
picking their words carefully when they
talk to me of all people even though we
are friends I wouldn't want to get
quoted I don't even like to ask someone
to do something which is not in their
political self-interest but yeah I would
say there are four to six votes for
removal right now so there are two
responses to this number one is no way
and number two is so what and I'll
explain each of those responses first of
all there is no evidence right now that
there are really four to six Republican
senators ready to convict Donald Trump
on impeachment in the Senate every
indication we have so far is that they
will go against impeachment Republicans
in the Senate will you might even see a
centrist Democrat like joe Manchin also
go against impeachment in the Senate but
can we come up with a list that is at
least circumstantially reasonable of
Republicans that might vote to convict
Donald Trump sure we talked about it
last week Susan Collins in Maine often a
candidate has been an occasional critic
of Trump but the caveat is in the end
she'll say a lot of things but in the
end she'll get in line like she did with
Brett Kavanaugh and his confirmation to
the Supreme Court
Mitt Romney senator from Utah Mitt
Romney has had many public disagreements
with Donald Trump they've had very acute
a bad blood between them I guess I would
say it's conceivable Mitt Romney might
say he would impeach
but previously when asked he has not
given any indication that he would Lisa
Murkowski from Alaska her name always
comes up anytime they say well here's a
more reasonable Republican who might
depart from Republican orthodoxy her
name is mentioned Cory Gardner there's a
couple of others but as I said before
this is where we go from no way to so
what even a four to six Republicans vote
to convict Trump it won't remove Trump
and it will get those Republicans
ostracized by the Republican Party
because remember you need two-thirds of
the Senate that's 67 senators to vote to
convict in order to remove the president
there are 45 Democrats and two
independents that caucus with the
Democrats that means you need to find 20
Republicans if you have maybe four to
six you don't have the numbers now the
argument would be in order to be
thorough here the argument would be if
there are already four to six
Republicans and we haven't even had a
trial there could be more coming
there could be momentum the best path to
making removal of Trump a reality is
something that's not going to happen
which is if the Senate passes a measure
to make make impeachment votes a secret
ballot where they vote privately instead
of publicly this way you could have
exactly 20 Republicans vote to impeach
it would get Trump removed but no one
would initially know which were the 20
that voted to convict but again there is
no indication that there exists a
political appetite for this in the
Republican Party and the question also
is could such a measure even be passed
with Mitch McConnell running the show in
the Senate as Majority Leader given that
he says the White House will be in total
coordination with him as to how the
Senate trial would be run certainly the
White House would know that a secret
ballot would not be advantageous to
Donald Trump because it would allow some
Republicans to vote to convict without
suffering the political consequences and
the wrath of Trump as a result very
difficult to imagine that Mitch
McConnell even let's that be a serious
discussion that's what we know so far
tell me what you think agree disagree if
you're watching on YouTube leave a
comment of course after hitting like and
subscribe if you're watching or list
anywhere else send me a tweet at de
Pakman and I believe we will have a
follow-up story about this on the David
Pakman show
Instagram which you can find at david
pakman show on your Instagram app